health officials are warning millions of  people about a rare but potentially  deadly mosquito bite infected mosquitos  have been spreading eastern equine  encephalitis the virus has killed at  least three people in the US this year  in Massachusetts Michigan and Rhode  Island the CDC also reports cases in New  Jersey and North Carolina about 33  percent of the people infected with the  rare virus will die just pointing out  though only 2% of adults can be infected  six percent of children bitten actually  go down with I was up in Massachusetts  in August we're in a town nearby they  had they one person had gotten bitten by  this and that people were really  concerned a lot of people were staying  home at night because mosquitoes are out  and they want to get bit that's one of  the recommendations of the CDC wear long  clothing don't be sceeto friends do they  have any redeeming values for this earth